chaque matin je livre des tonnes
d'informations personnelles sont comblés
de mots c'est hier qu'a été lancé un web
documentaire qui fait déjà beaucoup
jaser traque interdite
un webdoc produit entre autres par
l'office national du film qui permet à
l'internaute de voir ce qu'on lui cache
généralement soit les traces qu'il
laisse lorsqu'ils naviguent giga bonsoir
webdoc un hybride hybride entre un site
web et un documentaire classique donc où
l'internaute est appelé à participer
avec le documentariste à la création de
l'oeuvre donc on n'est pas passif le
dans un webdoc et qui est derrière ce
web de bayer l'eau nf your heart il ya
le diffuseur public allemand bayrischer
rundfunk
il ya aussi l'oeil documentariste
canadien brett gaylor qui chapeaute tout
ça est une documentariste québécois
sandra rodriguez qui participent à l'un
de ses épisodes
il y en a deux en ligne actuelle alors
comment ça fonctionne exactement premier
épisode par exemple celui où on va on
nous dit on nous demande de d'expliquer
que les notre routine matinale lorsqu'on
voit sur le web donc on écrit par
exemple le site web qu'on va consulter
pour nos informations et ça nous montre
toutes les traces que cette connexion le
laisse dans le deuxième épisode on nous
explique comment les cookies sont des
petits fichiers qui sont envoyées par
les sites web pour faciliter notre
navigation
mais ces coquilles il nous trace aussi
nous permettre de suivre vraiment tous
nos déplacements sur sur le web
et là ça devient quand même à ses
propres problématiques parce que c'est
souvent sans notre consentement et donc
c'est pour que les gens soient
conscients vraiment de ce qu'ils
souhaitent
quand on clique sur n'importe quelle
surface est amèrement de voir ces traces
laissées là que c'est vraiment très
intéressant parce que évidemment on veut
pas qu'on le sache
toutes ces traces le conditions le web
bon la grande question comment faire
pour ne pas laisser d'autres ajustements
mais c'est très compliqué folie dans le
menu nos navigateurs faut cliquer sur
des fenêtres pour interdire les cookies
il ya aussi des programmes aussi qu'on
peut télécharger pour permet se
permettre pour permettre de campus
naviguer de manière
anonyme on pense par exemple à
disconnect mais il ya quand même un
enjeu qui est tellement grande aire ce
qu'on rend sa passe est difficile de
l'enjeu les monétaires youtube fait 5
milliards de dollars l'année passée avec
les publicités on estime que les
publicités vidéo sur facebook d'ici 2017
ce sera à peu près le même montant
également donc il ya beaucoup d'argent
qui est la dent donc on veut cibler des
publicités on veut cibler des
consommateurs et c'est pour ça que tout
le monde et après nous oui on a appris
également avec eux mêmes que facebook je
suivais même les gens qui sont pas
abonnés à comps abonnés et ce même dans
les conditions d'utilisation et très
clair avec ça parce que on ne peut on
peut ne pas être abonné à facebook ali
sur un profil public et à partir de ce
moment-là facebook nous suit à la trace
pour mieux nous pour mieux nous cibler
alors même quand on ne veut pas faire
partie de ces choses là on est un peu
malgré eux mais on sait pas ce qui
arrive avec tout ces 2007 parce qu'ils
arrivent avec ces données là ici ce qui
est intéressant dans tracks interdite
c'est que d'une part on nous le montre
est de plus en plus céline ce qu'il faut
souligner aussi c'est que les programmes
pour nous permettre de naviguer de
manière plus anonymes sont plus faciles
d'accès sont plus faciles à utiliser
alors on pourrait penser que dans un
futur proche ça devienne plus facile
pour les internautes de se soustraire à
cette grande oeil inquisiteur
il faut souligner un de travail comme
traque interdite qui permet en tout cas
de nous le montrer de nous les montrer
ses principes et de prendre conscience
merci beaucoup à tous les instants